let me ask you the in in some of the
movies and some of the shows that it's
been so popularized in pop culture is
that is there a character that you see
and you're like i think they took that
from from my dad i think that guy is is
is kind of playing the sunny front seas
no but i'll tell you this i think the
greatest
performance of an actor
in one of those movies was armand asante
in the gotti movie in 1996.
he was tremendous to me
i i could watch that movie a hundred
times guy can you just because
good luck the guys uh i mean
maybe one of the best looking guys in
hollywood he was in mambo kings with
antonio honduras he crushed it the guy's
a beast of a guy and his voice judge
he's got a voice you cannot teach that
voice no yeah
yeah he's uh oh yeah stop how old is he
now he's about 70.
let's see what he in
i don't know what part of it images go
images
to see how
he is that travolta yeah travolta
it was probably one of the worst movies
i've seen in my life two hours later i
felt like i wanted to brief on my two
hours
and travolta is a great actor he just
didn't get gottie and he didn't get it
by the way this this guy is
[Laughter]
well he kills every role that he's in
but he just killed that rolling god i
mean who else did he played gotti better
than gotti to pick up gerard's question
who else comes to mind other than
armando and i thought you know next i
thought pacino and um donnie brasco
because i knew i knew uh lefty he was
terrified i thought that was his best
role really yes that and obviously uh
uh gosh
we played the cuban drug dealer oh
scarface scarface and he was great
but uh donnie brasco he was terrified i
think that guy pacino's gonna do
something good in hollywood so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]